hey everybody welcome back to kawali
beach episode number seven today i'm
here with just the late designer because
unfortunately corrales isn't home right
now so he can't be here to record with
us but the lady designer is here anyway
um here
awesome
yeah
i'm fine thank you how are you i am fine
too thank you and um today we are
finally working on the very long awaited
weenie of the park which is is it really
rainy time yes it's the weenies
supreme it's it's
the big thing which is gonna be built
right here which we've all been waiting
for so far i know there have been some
comments in the last video which we're
slightly worried about corrales building
through my weenie because he was kind of
building the lock flume on the spot
where i was planning to build my weenie
but it's more or less fine i can
definitely assure you that we had plenty
of talk before we went into that episode
to blend it all ahead and um basically i
want to integrate this weenie quite a
bit with the log flume because the big
weenie of the park is going to be this
big volcano a bit like
the volcano in volcano bay which is a
planned theme park in universal or what
i'm saying in universal but it's a
universal theme park
which is being built right now and it's
also a bit like disneysea tokyo which is
an amazing park in japan which i totally
still want to go to someday but
i'm not saying i ever can yeah it would
be so great but basically those are the
two big inspirations and um we actually
just talked about weenies uh quite a lot
just now because they they've been a
super big word recently haven't they and
they are indeed but i i had my first
episode of my new park let's build a
weenie and it was so funny like everyone
was like yeah you got that from some
bread and i was like
yeah but it's not really that he
um
came up with the name or anything like
that but it's really funny that
like me i
now know about weenie and i never heard
about it before thanks you
you're welcome i guess actually um
yeah i i kind of took the term from
disney i don't know why everybody's
thinking that it's from me i guess i at
least spread the term to the planet
coastal community but it's always been
absolutely yeah it's always been like
theme park jargon kind of thing which we
have to thank disney for i guess and i'm
not sure
exactly what history of this is accurate
because i've had many talks with people
about this and i've heard many kinds of
different stories but the one that i
find most and that i also find on the
internet is that um he basically he had
a dog that was coincidentally named lady
apparently
uh i'm not even kidding
and
um no there's the connection
exactly that's oh
yeah it's it's been a plan all along but
um basically he would use weenies like
the little sausages and um he would
notice that whenever he would carry a
weenie around like lady would follow him
so um
basically
that sounds super weird i am very well
aware of this i'm trying to keep my
straight face here but basically um
the connection was that a weenie is what
attracted the dog and in a similar kind
of sense he would plan out the weenies
in his park as like major parts of
attraction inside a park i've also heard
a story that he would explain to his
employees by using these sausages where
weenies in the park would be i'm not
sure if this is correct but it's kind of
similar idea basically a weenie is
something that you place in the park as
a kind of way-finding
concept that draws visitors towards a
certain thing because the basic concept
that underlies it all is basically if
you see your destination you're not
going to get lost finding it because you
can just see it anyway
so
i mean that's a pretty simple thing and
a pretty good way it sounds very
interesting it's really cool how you
made it up and it really makes sense
yeah actually uh i just think it's the
best thing that
he came up with this weird little word
which is now official jargon of the
theme park
field if you would say so and there are
like academic articles actual scientific
research on this on wayfinding theories
that have to use the word weenie because
that's the accepted term for it it's
it's ridiculous
but that's basically what we're making
i'm just thinking i love right now
because i'm like thinking like everyone
that is playing playing
knows your videos and knows about
weenies can you imagine them walking
around in a theme park look at that
that's the weenie like people don't even
know what they're talking about
it's so funny
okay but never mind itself
yeah definitely i i see weenies
everywhere in if i'm in the theme park
then again
i think many people can relate to this
like
if you're somebody who's just got into
theme parks once you started playing
planet coaster you start looking at
theme parks in a completely different
way i think true but to be honest the
only
theme park i know
having a weenie is not because the dutch
theme parks don't have it
um it's really something from disney
yeah it's definitely a disney term but i
would say the idea in wayfinding theory
that you have to make
some large areas stand out to draw
people towards certain areas is
definitely something you find elsewhere
so
for instance um the efteling is building
symbolica right now which is a castle
right in the middle of the park you know
about this one right yeah you do know oh
but i didn't know that it is in the
middle of the park is it that big that
people can see it as a weenie and see it
from
like
everywhere around it well it's it's not
that huge it's not an enormous building
but it's it's in the middle of the park
and you can definitely see it from a lot
of angles which i'm kind of not too
happy with because i think it's actually
an ugly piece of [ __ ] from the outside
but you know who am i to say this um
okay no really especially from the back
side i'm a business really that bad i
didn't think it is no it's good building
i just think for the afterling it's
quite disappointing but i'm waiting with
my judgement until it's finished because
who knows if they're still gonna add
some detailing to it i'm just not a big
fan of it right now but it definitely is
kind of weenie
because um it's something that you can
see from many areas and it's right up at
the end of the like the entrance path
you know right when you enter the
ethereum as the wide entrance path it's
right at the end of that and
you can see it from a lot of parts of
the ethylene so basically if you want to
get to that middle point where all the
parts come from you just have to look
for symbolica in the distance and you
can find it and go there so i definitely
think symbolica is a weenie as well and
the same goes for many other kinds of
things we've got baron 1898 in the park
which is this large dive coaster with an
awesome looking lift hill that's
definitely a weenie you can see that
thing from the entire
i don't know if it's from the entire
park but
well yeah true
it's cool
yeah it's basically like very cool you
maybe you can definitely
uh make like subweenies and
regular weenie weenies
so
maybe you know the volcano in this case
is for instance the real big winnie of
the park in a sense that um cinderella's
castle is the weaning of disneyland and
in the sense that the volcano is the
winner of disneysea and
in the sense that um
spaceship earth is the winning of epcots
basically these huge things you've got
in the middle of the park that you see
from almost the entire park and then
you've got the little subweenies which
can be anything i think the entrance
is already in itself kind of a subweenie
because it does kind of stick from
everything else it really draws you into
the park or the station of the wooden
coaster is kind of a weenie as well
because it's visible from a lot of
places and draws you into this area with
wooden coaster i know i'm sounding
ridiculously
um like passionate about this subject at
this point
well it's funny you mentioned that
because i was thinking like before we
started to record you were saying let's
talk about weenies no no we better not
do that and now we are talking about
weenies for like five to ten minutes
already yep this is what i figured
yeah we're already well over five
minutes into the other part of the
timelapse which is just the paths but we
were talking about that earlier and we
were just like
i'm not sure if we should talk about
parts because it's you know it's parts
what what is there to say you walk on
them and we need them for people to go
places
absolutely so it's not really
interesting to talk about pot
but you can talk about your news if you
want to um i think i've covered most of
the weenie theory for today and um maybe
i'll conclude it with uh i don't know
i'm thinking about making a video essay
on it some other day but
we'll see you know um i'll i'll get
tired on the topic at some point in time
but um
yeah basically basically at this point
i'm just doing
the general foliage and the pathworks
and all of the detailing around this
area because that's something that we
kind of still haven't done yet
everything so far has just been you know
a little bit disconnected we have the
entrance and the restaurant which do go
really well together um
you know so that's i guess one fitting
thing but everything else has sort of
been very separate so it's already yeah
but what corrales made
like my jungle restaurant and his uh
luck flume ride is so awesome fitting
together already
yeah it's perfect and he stole your
roofs as well
yeah he did
bad corrales
at least it looks good i don't know it
is okay because i stole your roofs as
well for my uh restaurant at the
entrance so
and we told each other like if you want
to use something from the other just do
it
yeah exactly
we wanted to
fit together right
everything together
so yeah
he stole my roof but it's okay
and someone commented on one of my
videos like he did that that watch out
right on the
at the lock flumes like above it you can
you have some benches and you can walk
down uh yeah you can look down
and someone commented like it would be
so awesome if you
would have like
something like a passport stand by which
we hide in a roller coaster come three
or something with a ticket booth
or some some how you call that
stem like like something little to
attract the people going up there that
will be so cool but we don't have that
right now do we that's true
you mean the little the little plateau
with the roof over it where you can
watch over the log flume yeah exactly
but i don't expect anyone to go there
right now that would be very awesome if
they would add something like a small
detail
that people would go there
yeah one of the things which i love
about this area is like how intertwined
everything is so like the paths and the
ride and everything is going over each
other and it's it's all very
interconnected
yeah it's very cool it does make it kind
of a shame that nobody's probably gonna
go there
yes exactly
so i think someone already mentioned it
on the four so
let's just keep our fingers crossed that
they will add something like that
in time before we
finish the park so we can end it up that
will be so cool i guess
oh yeah definitely it's just a little
details but
yeah we need it
planet coaster we need it
well there's definitely more stuff that
we need i guess but then again i have no
idea what other updates we're gonna get
same i'm sure we will get other update
updates and expansion packs but
who knows what it will be
maybe except for planet safari i guess
because that's the one thing that
they're probably going to do anyway
there's cheeky safari but i think before
that we will have
other updates as well i'm sure with that
what kind of scenery objects would you
most like to see in the game actually
a scenery yeah like very specific single
objects
well i already asked them for like
attached roof the corners and like the i
don't know how to call them you remember
when you had like
a downloadable set for radical second
three when you had i think it was the
main street set you had more sets of
that
and you had like these small
props or whatever you call them with
open doors
it's just something very little but i
really think that if you have an archer
and you place a shop inside of a
building with those open doors i would
love that like
it really
finished up your restaurant or anything
like that but we don't have it right now
you only have closed doors that you can
put onto a wall through you know what i
mean yeah yeah i exactly know what you
mean i have the same kind of feeling
about windows because all of the windows
that we have right now
are like you slap them onto a building
but they're not transparent and it would
also be cool to have like
in-wall windows that you can see through
yeah that will be awesome as well i just
trust them to do what is right for the
game but we need to realize that it is a
lot of work like small things we ask
can be like hours of work for them i
guess definitely and even if it's not
time is money as well and there's always
a cost versus benefit kind of idea
behind everything they put into the game
so that's definitely true you've got a
good point there the one thing that i'm
really wanting to see in the game and i
know that other people have talked about
this as well and this is why i'm kind of
scared of posting on the forums but now
that you say that
maybe i should um it's
it's like one piece
it's transparent glass because we know
that they have transparent glass because
they have it in some of the lanterns but
it would be not only in the lanterns you
also have something oh the small roof
it's what was with blue yeah i don't
know i think you mean the small like
round roof piece yeah yeah exactly yeah
that one has a beautiful glass texture
but we we can't actually use it and it
would be amazing to just have like flat
glass that we can put anywhere and make
our own windows out of or even like
modern buildings that kind of stuff
only if it's only like a quarter piece
and a half wall piece and a big wall
piece like i think we can manage a lot
with that
like making your own borders and that
kind of stuff
yep so another point for the forums i
guess do itself
yeah maybe i should try it speaking of
half walls by the way the one thing that
i also see a lot of people talking about
are like half wall pieces not in terms
of height but in terms of
width so well that's just the width of
a quarter
grid you always need to uh to
um yeah just to kind of puzzle with the
pieces to get like yeah small walls in
yeah definitely absolutely it sucks
but we can do it it is manageable but it
will be easier if they just put in some
half walls i guess
yeah honestly if i'm very honest i am i
actually am somewhat confident we'll see
that in the future
but i don't want to make any things
about this because you know i'm not the
official person to talk about planet
coast whatsoever and i don't have any
information on this and i don't want to
be [ __ ] on the game's parade in any
way it's just
you know like i like to say there's
there's so many great things about this
game and it's pretty much everything
i've ever wanted in so many ways that
the the small things that still make me
about it
are sticking out so much
you know it's those small little extra
objects and stuff which i would love to
see added in the game and which i
definitely hope they will add in the
future because you know it's it's just
the start the original roller coaster 3
didn't really have that much compared to
the version with the expansion packs in
the end either
so you know we'll see true yeah let's
have that as well
so who knows who knows yeah they are
planning to uh support this game for a
very long term
so this is the intention like roller
coaster 3 was like like a 10 year hype
so this will be 20 year hype don't tell
the members of the community that's
because if i log on to the roller
coaster 3 community site right now they
are still active making stuff
so they are it's still hyped and oh i
wouldn't say that's a very cool thing
there's not that many people playing it
but i definitely think that it aged
better than most people think because
most of the videos that you see out
there of roller coaster second three are
just like
old ones of the standard game but with
all of the custom content and all of the
things that people have been making over
the years
i still think that roller coaster three
looks fantastic for the year that it
comes for the year that it came out and
really even
it's it's almost better than planets
coaster in some ways if you look at some
of the things that people have made and
i'm not bringing down um planet coast in
any way because you know there's 12
years of custom content in roller
coaster 3. it's that's true it's such an
amazing point for where frontier is
coming from of course
yeah that yeah that's true absolutely
absolutely
so yeah i i guess the thing is just
planet coaster is just right at the
start right now even if it just came out
there is a lot more to be expected from
the game
oh i can't wait to be honest
yup same
so uh how long is your video um well i
still have a little bit of time at this
point i am still working on the very
final things on the path work and just
adding some small buildings around the
site some trees and everything this was
actually heavily inspired by busch
gardens temper in real life and i know
you have no idea what this is like no
but definitely
okay so that was not intended to be a
subtle diss in any way
but basically i was just joking with you
yeah i know i know some some people will
understand what i'm on about hopefully
maybe we'll see but basically it's very
jungling and it's like parts that go
everywhere with lots of flowers you know
one of the flowers and like rubbery and
trees and stuff like that um so you know
it's it's just a small part area with
lots of
small details so that we can finally
close the chapter of the area around
here and um you can go on in the next
episode
about something and
we haven't really set our plans exactly
yet right
no no we don't but there was nice
yeah that was kind of the general plan
of the of the pond or something
oh you had yeah you said like it would
be nice to have like a small pond at the
end of the weenie
and i don't know what i'm gonna do i
need to see the park first in front of
my eyes i didn't got your save file yet
but while we are talking about people
are looking at this video i will
probably but
until i have it i'm not quite sure what
to do
so you're right i know you're really
using it
uh no but i never have how long do you
know me now so well i know i never have
it at least you must have some idea i
know i know you just kind of weighing it
but
is there nothing that you feel you
really want to do like you imagine you
want to see
i am going to fix my jungle restaurant
first
because rather screwed it up that's the
first thing and i don't know if i'm
gonna record it record it sorry record
it good job
i'm learning i'm learning
and um
i have no idea no
but i never have a plan so it's nothing
new for the people that know me
i know you don't ever have a plan or an
idea but isn't there something in your
body that's saying man i would love to
see a pirate ship in here or man i would
love to see this other ride in here like
or whatever yeah i would no not really
for this part but i would love to make a
rapid ride but that's a good point i i
i have something in mind for rapid ride
but not
not intentionally for crowley reach but
maybe maybe not i don't know
i really have no plan
so you're gonna build a rapid ride in um
in your western network
maybe
or maybe quali beach i don't know
oh you're seriously doubting okay yes i
am seriously
oh wow because they would fit both
themes like
that is definitely true
yeah
maybe i do it both that could be a thing
too
whatever you feel like honestly i'm just
giving you this park file with my
half-finished mess over parts just
because i'm leaving others
to fix my [ __ ] basically
and maybe maybe i delete your weenie
maybe
that's okay don't worry about it too no
i wouldn't dare to do that it's just a
weenie
yeah
this butterweeny still the weenies the
weenies rug
future like weenies yeah
yeah it was a blast
sorry
it was a blast to record this episode um
but um i think it's about time to leave
you guys
i guess
this is it guys it's it's it's it's no
problem though because next time we'll
be back at the lay designers channel and
whisk corrales with gorillas hopefully
if he's all well and home and not sick
again oh he's not sick but he's just not
home i i i don't remember where he was
going but i know he told us like two or
three weeks ago
guys the week of 18th of january and not
be able to record record and he was like
i'm going to some place and it's very
important you must remember what it was
and you know entity
he didn't work
i know i hope he didn't i can't remember
anyway um but it's like
he's he's sick every other week and he's
also going somewhere every other week
he's a busy man poor guy yeah true
so uh
we will we we will see him in the next
video on my channel i guess
yeah he'll be there we'll be fine yeah
so thank you for having me
it's no problem thank you for being here
and being an awesome guest
and um having to be so quiet during my
passionate talks about weenies i'm so
sorry
i am patiently waiting till you finish
your talk about your weenies
yeah thank you the viewer of course
thank you for watching this video again
and always feel free to leave some
feedback about what we should do uh
don't worry about too much whether we're
ruining each other each other's plans
though because we're just coming up with
this stuff along the way i'm not mad at
corrales for building the log flume
there that was actually the plan all the
way through um
so leave your feet and i'm not mad that
he moved my restaurant because we talked
about it like yeah it could be that my
restaurant will be moved and i was like
yeah sure
do whatever you have to
so that'll be fine but if you have any
ideas on the park or stuff that you like
or stuff that you would like us to talk
about you can always feel free to leave
that in the comment section and we'll
see you guys next week
bye guys thanks guys bye
[Music]
[Music]
you